Bitte schön.
Guten Abend.
Ich bin Okua und ja, ich, ich bin, ja, ich bin als, ich bin hier als Arzt tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anämnesegich befürchten.
Sind Sie damit einfach standen?
Ja, bin ich.
Ja, ich würde gerne Ihnen ein paar gemeine Fragen stellen bevor Sie mir über Ihre Beschwerden erzählen.
Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, ja, das ist in Ordnung.
Ja, wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Alexander Schlüter.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen bestabieren?
Alexander Schlüter schreibt sich S-C-H-L-U-T-E-R.
Schlüter.
Ja.
Herr Schlüter, wie heißen Sie?
Ähm, ich bin 23 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geworden?
17. Mai 2001.
Ja, wie groß sind Sie?
1,84 m.
4,84 m, ja.
Ja.
Wie groß sind Sie so seit?
Wie schwer, wie schwer, wie groß 1,84 m?
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
76 kg.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten, Herr Schlüter?
Nein, Allergien habe ich nicht.
Unverträglichkeiten habe ich auch nicht.
Ich habe allerdings Allergie, Ja, Hausstaub und Getreide,
deswegen, weil ich auch Asthma habe.
Vielleicht kann man das als Allergie bezeichnen.
Ja, ja.
Was kann ich für Sie tun, Herr Schlüter?
Ja, ich habe so in den letzten Tagen,
vielleicht fünf Tage, da bin ich zunehmend müde und schlapp.
Ich bin schwach und ich habe Fieber.
Das geht mir nicht gut.
Ich fühle mich ganz müde und kaputt.
Ja, haben Sie das Fieber gemessen?
Ja, ich habe 39 gemessen.
39.
Haben Sie Rusten?
Rusten habe ich eigentlich nicht besonders.
Ich habe ja mit Asthma zu tun, aber mehr Husten als sonst habe ich jetzt nicht.
Da hat sich nichts geändert in den letzten Tagen.
Ja, haben Sie Halsschmerzen oder Kopfschmerzen?
Ja, ich habe ein bisschen Halsschmerzen, auch beim Schlucken.
Seitlich am Halsbereich habe ich den Eindruck, es ist dicker.
Da ist der Hals dicker auf der rechten und auf der linken Seite hier.
Das fühlt sich irgendwie dicker an.
Ich kann nicht gut einen Rollkragen-Pullover anhaben.
Das ist mir zu eng.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schluckbechwerden?
Ja, auch.
Haben Sie Luftknoten?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das Lymphknoten sind,
aber es fühlt sich dicker an auf der Seite, auf der rechten und auf der linken Seite hier am Hals.
Es fühlt sich dicker an.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das Lymphknoten sind.
Ich kann das nicht sagen.
Okay.
Haben Sie laufende Nase?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie etwas gegen diese Beschwerden unternehmen?
Nein, ich habe mich nur ins Bett gelegt und habe viel geschlafen.
Jetzt bin ich heute hier, weil es eben nicht besser wird.
Ich fühle mich noch schlapper.
Haben Sie Covid-Noise schnell gemacht?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise ist der Appetit gut, aber seit fünf Tagen, seitdem ich jetzt auch Fieber habe,
habe ich keinen guten Appetit, habe ich wenig gegessen.
Haben Sie nacktweiss oder...
Ich schwitze nachts sehr stark.
Hat Ihr Gewicht in Letzter Night verändert?
Nein, Gewicht hat sich nicht verändert.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Ja, wenn ich jetzt schnell aufstehe vom Bett hoch komme, da muss ich erst mal sitzen bleiben.
Sonst habe ich den Eindruck gemacht, meinen Kreislauf nicht so gut mit.
Normalerweise kenne ich das nicht, normalerweise treibe ich auch viel Sport,
aber das kann ich zurzeit nicht.
Ich finde, ich bin zu kaputt, zu schlapp.
Okay, haben Sie Übelkeit oder Erbrechen?
Nein, die Übelkeit oder Erbrechen habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Luftnot?
Zurzeit habe ich keine Luftnot, nein.
Leiden Sie unter Herzrasen?
Nein, ich habe den Eindruck, der Puls ist etwas höher.
Ich habe hier eine Pulsuhr, aber das hängt mit dem Fieber zusammen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Sturrgang?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Herr Schluter, leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ich habe Asthma seit um zehn Jahren.
Da bin ich getestet worden, auf Hausstaub reagiere ich allergisch mit Asthma-Symptomen
und auch Getreidepollen.
Da muss ich eben einen Sprech nehmen und etwas mit Cortison nehme ich.
Das nehme ich regelmäßig ein.
Vor zwei Jahren wurde an meinem Herzen eine Operation vorgenommen.
Da war ein Loch in der Herzscheidewand, das sich normalerweise nach der Geburt verschließt.
Das ist aber offen geblieben.
Da haben die Herzspezialisten im Herzzentrum ein kleines, wie so einen Schirm eingesetzt, um das abzudichten.
Das Ergebnis ist wohl gut. Ich lasse das regelmäßig beim Kardiologen kontrollieren.
Ich habe regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Asthma schiebt.
Ich nehme einmal etwas, das heißt Boudisonit, das sie zu Kapseln, Pulverkapseln, die drücke ich in so ein Apparat.
Dann muss ich das einatmen.
Das mache ich zweimal am Tag und dann nehme ich manchmal noch Salbutamolspray.
Wie viel pro Tag?
Zwei bis dreimal.
Herr Schluter, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich glaube schon, dass ich alle Impfungen zur Zeit habe, die hier empfohlen werden für meinen Antrag.
Das habe ich auch.
Aber wie gesagt, ich war damit beim Hausarzt und er sagte im Augenblick, bin ich ausreichend geimpft.
Ich möchte ein paar Fragen zu Ihren Lebensgewohnheiten stellen.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Nein, ja.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, so ein bis zweimal pro Woche trinke ich eine Flasche Bier.
Aber nicht jeden Tag.
Nicht jeden Tag, ja.
Nehmen Sie nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Nehmen Sie Drogen ein?
Nein, nehme ich nicht.
Herr Schluter, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, die Eltern, der Vater ist 52 Jahre alt, der hat auch Asthma, so wie ich.
Und die Mutter, die ist auch 52 Jahre alt, die hatte vor drei Jahren Brustkrebs
und wurde operiert und mit Chemotherapie behandelt und mit Bestrahlung.
Und die letzten Kontrollen waren so weit stabil, also die waren zufrieden, die Ärztinnen und Ärzte.
Ich habe noch einen Bruder, der ist 18 Jahre alt, der hat auch Asthma und Neurodermitis.
Und eine Schwester, die ist 20 Jahre alt, die hatte eine vergrößerte Schilddrüse mit einer Unterfunktion.
Und da muss sie immer auch Schilddrüsenhomone und Tabletten nehmen.
Ja, Herr Schluter, sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin nicht verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Ja, was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich studiere noch Geschichte und Englisch.
Geschichte?
Ja, Herr Schluter, ich habe von meiner Seite alle wichtige Fragen gestattet.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder fragen Sie an mich?
Ja, ich bin mir natürlich überhaupt nicht sicher, was das sein kann.
Ich habe mich eigentlich immer ganz gut gefühlt.
Hab ich immer regelmäßig mein Sport gemacht bis vor fünf Tagen und dann ging das aber nicht mehr?
Ja, diese Krankheit ist heilbar.
Ich kann nicht genau sagen, aber ich gehe davon aus, dass die eine Probleme mit
einer Erkältung kommt.
Ach so, und dann auch so hohes Fieber.
Ja, um eine Abschließende diagnostische Ställe zu können,
müssen wir weiter unterzuken und durchführen.
Okay, das können wir so machen.
Sie haben jetzt etwas länger Zeit, aber ich würde trotzdem Kollegen bitten,
die jetzt zugehört haben, zugeschaut haben,
vielleicht noch zwei, drei wichtige Fragen zu stellen, die noch nicht gestellt worden sind.
Die sind jetzt absolut wichtig, diese Fragen, die müssen wir noch beantworten,
damit sie sich der Diagnose etwas nähern können.
Ja.
Was fehlt noch?
Ich habe meine Familie und meine Freunde in Giptes geholfen.
Nein, nicht.
In meinem Umfeld hat niemand so etwas.
Ja, sind Sie auf der Kurse, ja, haben Sie auf der Kurse seit Reise gemacht?
Eine Reise, ja, ich war vor ungefähr drei Monaten,
war ich für drei Wochen in Thailand, da habe eine Rundreise gemacht durch Thailand.
Ja.
Und da ging es mir eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich hatte einmal kurz etwas so eine Markendam-Infektion für einen Tag,
aber das war dann wieder gut.
Welche Frage würde sich jetzt...
Dort hatten Sie welche in der Partnerschaft?
Welche Frage würde sich jetzt direkt anschließen?
Der Patient war auf einer Fernreise in Asien, in Thailand.
Ja.
Sollten Sie die Frage stellen, waren Sie in einem Malaria-Gebiet?
Haben Sie eine Malaria-Profilaxe betrieben?
Ich war in einem Malaria-Gebiet, aber nur kurz, aber Malaria-Profilaxe habe ich nicht betrieben.
Ja.
Ich habe zwei Impfungen gemacht für Thailand, Hepatitis-Impfung und so,
aber Malaria-Profilaxe habe ich nicht betrieben.
Da habe ich so viel Schlechtes gehört, dass die Leute das nicht so gut vertragen
und dann habe ich das nicht eingenommen.
Ist der Fieber dauerhafter oder kommt und geht?
Ja, ich meine, es ist wechselnd.
Morgen ist das Fieber etwas niedriger, aber immerhin mindestens immer 38.
Und gegen Abend dann eben 39.
Und hatten Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden?
So was habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Haben Sie Schluckbeschwerden oder Heiserkeit?
Ja, Schluckbeschwerden habe ich und wie gesagt, mein Hals ist so auf beiden Seiten,
habe ich den Eindruck etwas dicker.
Das fühlt sich dicker an.
Ich weiß aber nicht, der Kollege hat gefragt, sind es Lymphknoten?
Ich kann das nicht beurteilen, ob das Lymphknoten sind.
Ich verstand.
Aber die Pauselasse, es gibt noch eine ganz wichtige Frage,
die noch nicht gestellt worden ist.
Aber diese Symptome sind infectious, man hat ein Closer.
Und deswegen, ich denke, alle Fragen gestellt.
Ist die Frage schon nach Operationen gestellt worden?
Ist die Ihnen eventuell schon Hautveränderung oder Einmitteln aufgefallen?
Nein, Hautveränderung nicht.
Aber die Frage nach Operationen ist noch nicht gestellt.
Noch nicht.
Als Kind bin ich am Leistenbruch operiert worden,
auf der rechten Seite.
Und dann eben vor zwei Jahren hatte ich diese kleine Herzoperation
mit diesem Schirm in der Scheidewand, in dem Loch.
Und vor 14 Tagen wurde mir ein Backenzahn gezogen, der war entzündet.
Und das war vor 14 Tagen.
Backenzahn, die ein Zahn und an der Backenzahn.
Ein Zahn gezogen wahrscheinlich?
Vor zwei Wochen.
Und es war danach noch ziemlich stark gespollen.
Ich war einmal danach noch mal beim Zahnarzt.
Der war aber ganz zufrieden damit.
Der Zahn war ein bisschen entzündet.
Ich könnte gerne diese folgende Frage,
fragen, was können wir stellen, infektiös endokalitis prophylaxis?
Ja, hat der Zahnarzt Ihnen zum Beispiel ein Antibiotikum aufgeschrieben?
Weiß der Zahnarzt von Ihrer Herzoperation?
Ja.
Ich glaube nicht, dass der Zahnarzt das weiß.
Er hat mich aber auch nicht danach gefragt.
Und ich habe aber auch kein Antibiotikum bekommen.
Wir haben jetzt neue Aspekte.
Und jetzt machen Sie mal in aller Ruhe.
Lassen Sie sich jetzt mal Zeit, weil wenn wir jetzt viel durcheinander reden,
glaube ich, das ist für Sie jetzt auch nicht gut.
Dann können Sie sich nicht auf Ihre Schilderung konzentrieren.
Ich würde mal vorschlagen, wir machen jetzt mal mindestens,
jetzt haben wir 20 nach 6, sollen wir sagen bis halb 7?
Ist das in Ordnung?
Ja, halb 7, ja.
Ja, danke schön.
Also ich habe es noch so 9 Minuten ungefähr.
9 Minuten, okay, danke schön.
Also unser Geschenk und Terbligation.
Ja, können wir, also können wir gerne machen.
Der Patient ist 23 Jahre alt, nicht 26.
Er ist 2001 geboren, 2001, 23 Jahre alt.
Herr Schlüter ist ein 23-jähriger Patient, 1,84 m groß, 76 kg schwer,
würde ich immer ergänzend kurz sagen, der sich heute bei uns vorstellte.
Er berichtet über febrile Temperaturen bis 39 Grad seit 5 Tagen.
Zunehmende Fatigue-Symptomatik mit Hyperhydrosis, besonders in der Nacht,
Nachtschweiß, ja, Hyperhydrosis.
Und er berichtet über Dysphagie, Schluckbeschwerden, Dysphagie
und von unklaren, bisher unklaren Schwellungen im Zervikalbereich lateral,
also beidseits lateral, Schwellung im Zervikalbereich.
Bilateral Servikal Lymphadenopathy,
können wir sagen, Bilateral Servikal Lymphadenopathy.
Ja, aber der Patient, wir wissen ja noch nicht, ob es eine Lymphadenopathy ist.
Der Patient berichtet über diese Schwellung erstmal.
Lymphadenopathy ist vorausgesetzt, dass sie den Patienten ja schon untersucht haben
und sich ein Bild gemacht haben, ja, das können Lymphknoten sein
oder es ist etwas anders.
Ich würde erst mal sagen, er berichtet über zunächst unklare zervikale Schwellungen,
beidseits lateral und eine Dysphagie.
Ja, also wir haben Fieber, wir haben Fatigue,
abgeschlagenheit, wahrscheinlich Atralgien und Myalgien, das ist begleitend oft.
Dann haben wir die Dysphagie und wir haben die zervikalen Schwellungen.
Gut, gibt es sonstige Auffälligkeiten bei dem Patienten?
Ja, hat er sonst etwas geschältet?
Gibt es Erbrechen, gibt es Durchfall?
Ich sage bewusst die allgemeinen Namen.
Ja, die Fragen nach, die Fragen nach über, ja, nahe der, durch, ja, ja,
der oder aus der Passion, takikhardi und diese wurden verneint.
Okay, okay, wichtig, dann haben Sie das abgefragt und haben Sie das erfragt vom Patienten, sehr gut.
Fahren Sie bitte fort.
Ja.
An vorerkrankungen, nicht folgende Bekan.
Der Patient hat leidet an Brunjel Asthma seit zehn Jahren.
Okay.
Er nimmt Budefonit, Budefonit, täglich zweimal und bei Bedarf salvitamal ein.
Gibt es irgendeine Ursache dieses Asthma, ist der Patient auf der,
Ursache Hautstaub.
Hausstaub, ja, und noch etwas anderes.
Poland, Poland, ja.
Getreide, Getreide, auf Getreide, Getreide, Poland.
Getreide, Getreide, Poland von Blumen, von Wiesenblumen, es gibt aber auch Getreide.
Viele Menschen sind auf Getreide, wenn das Getreide gemäht wird, sind sie allergisch,
dann reagieren sie auf den Staub am Getreide.
Gut, gibt es sonstige chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, bei chronischen, sonstigen Operationen, ja.
Ja.
Ja, bei dem Patient, bei dem Patient wurde,
Atrial Septum Defect, operiert duschgeführt.
Ja, wahrscheinlich wurde bei dem Patienten vor zwei Jahren wegen eines Septum Defects,
ein, wie nennt sich das Okluda, Okluda Oklusion, ein Okluda, ein Schirm eingesetzt.
Ja, ja, Schirm.
Septum Defect, wurde verschlossen.
Mit Katheter, ja.
Wahrscheinlich mit Katheter, mittels Katheter, also ein,
nicht am offenen Herzen operiert worden.
Gut, gibt es andere Operationen bei dem Patienten?
Ja, als Kind war, wurde der Patient in Gülenherne, ja, in Gülenherne, Doktor Busch.
Ja, man kann sagen, wurde eine Herneotomie, eine Herneotomie durchgeführt.
Ja, wegen Ingwinalherne, ja, in der Kindheit.
Gut. Ja.
Ja und, Steen, oder, wie viel Tagen sehen Operationen, ja?
Nein, nein, ja.
Wie viel, da?
Vor zwei Wochen.
Ja, vor zwei Wochen, ihre,
Ich weiß nicht, woher ist der?
Nein, nicht mal.
Malio?
Malio ist denke, Herr Hayko.
Malio.
Malio, Sieg.
Vor zwei Wochen wurde etwas durchgeführt, eine Zahnextraktion.
Der Zahnarzt hat vor dem Operation Antibiotika verschrieben.
Ja, vor zwei Wochen wurde bei den Patienten eine Zahnextraktion durchgeführt.
Der Zahn hatte sich offenkundig entzündet.
Ja.
Der Zahnarzt hat vor dem Operation Antibiotika verschrieben.
Nein, hat er nicht.
Nein, nein, nein.
Keine Antibiotika.
Man muss sagen, eine endokarditis Profilaxel wurde nicht durchgeführt.
Der Patient hat kein Antibiotikum bekommen.
Aber Arzt verschrieben oder keine verschrieben?
Nein, er hat nicht verschrieben.
Der Arzt hat das nicht verschrieben.
Arzt verschrieben, aber...
Vor zwei Jahren fand die SEPTUM OP statt.
Der Patient wird kardiologisch kontrolliert, hat der Patient gesagt, regelmäßig.
Wahrscheinlich hat der Kardiologe zu ihm gesagt, er muss eine endokarditis Profilaxe durchführen,
bei bestimmten Eingriffen.
Wahrscheinlich.
Aber der Zahnarzt hat keine endokarditis Profilaxe betrieben.
Das ist zumindest eine wichtige Information,
für die Diagnostik zumindest auch wichtige Informationen.
Gut, gibt es sonst Auffälligkeiten bei den Patienten?
Gewicht zu halten?
Ja, gewichtstabil, ja.
Unaufhellig, Sie können sagen, das Gewicht zu halten ist unauffällig.
Der Patient hat sein Gewicht in letzten Jahren gehalten.
Gut, gibt es sonst etwas bezüglich Rauchen, Alkohol, Drucken?
Ja, er ist vollständig geimpft gegen Kinderkrankheit.
Und er raucht, der Patient ist nicht raucher.
Eine gute Formulierung, der Patient ist nicht raucher.
Drogenkonsum wird verneinigt.
Alkoholkonsum, 1, 2, vielleicht ein Bier, nicht jeden Tag.
Ja, pro Woche, man kann sagen 1 bis 2 Flaschen Bier pro Woche.
Gut, ja, sehr gut.
Gibt es sonstige Auffälligkeiten in der kürzeren Anamnese des Patienten,
die wichtig erscheinen?
Ja, noch einmal bitte.
Hat der Patient in den letzten Monaten eine Fernreise gemacht?
Ja, die müssen Sie erwähnen.
Der Patient hat nach Thailand Reise gemacht.
Der Patient ist vor 4 Monaten nach Thailand gereist
und hat sich dort ungefähr 3 Wochen aufgehalten.
Und der Patient ist für die Reise in Funken.
Ja, aber noch eine wichtige Information hat der Patient gesagt.
Malaria?
Malaria, aber keine Propylaxie.
Der Patient hat keine Malaria Propylaxie betrieben.
Das ist auch eine wichtige Information, die darf nicht fehlen.
Gerade bei einem Patienten, der 39 Temperatur Fieber hatte.
Ja, 39.
Gut, ich fasse das jetzt mal zusammen.
Der Patient hat seit 5 Tagen Fieber bis 39 Grad.
Wo misst er die Temperatur?
Haben Sie das gefragt?
Ich habe es ja gewusst.
Der Patient misst das und endet im Mund.
Im Mund.
Also er hat seit 5 Tagen Fieber, 39 Grad.
Er hat Nachtschweiße,
er hat servikale Schwellungen.
Und er hat dysphagie.
Er hat keine Diarrheu, kein Erbrechen,
keine wesentliche Übelkeit.
Ich nenne es jetzt wo da Nausea und Emesis.
Er hat unauffällige Mikzion.
Ja.
In der Vorgeschichte ist erwähnenswert bei chronischen Erkrankungen
eine Asthma-Bronchale seit 10 Jahren.
Das mit Boudisonit und Salbutamol behandelt wird.
Ist wohl positiv auf Hausstaub und Getreidepollen getestet worden.
Vor 2 Jahren wurde eine Septumverschluss
und war noch persistieren im Septum-Deffekt durchgeführt.
Er ist in kardiologischer Kontrolle.
Er erfolgt eine Herneutomie
bei Inguennalherne.
Er erwähnenswert aktuell ist eine Zahnextraktion vor 14 Tagen.
Vor 2 Wochen bei den Patienten war es ein Backenzahn.
Und rechts der Zahn sei entzündet gewesen.
Er war in der Erkrankung von der Erkrankung von der Erkrankung
von der Erkrankung von der Erkrankung von der Erkrankung von der Erkrankung
von der Erkrankung von der Erkrankung von der Erkrankung und faster zu würde.
Sie die Reprim inverter hatten ein
Brustkrebs.
Ja, jeder Mutter.
Mama.
Ja, die 52-jährige Mutter.
Ja.
Hatte vor drei Jahren ein Mama-Karzinom.
Das war Karzinom behandelt.
Behandelt Chemotherapie und Strahlentherapie.
Ja, erste Operation.
Erst Operation ja.
Die Strahlentherapie.
Kennen Sie noch einen Begriff dazu?
Wir sagen in Deutschland noch Radio-Azio.
Radio-Azio.
Die Mutter wurde mittels Operation, Chemotherapie und Radio-Azio behandelt.
Gibt es Geschwister?
Ja, Geschwister, 20 Jahre alt.
Hypo-Troi...
Hypo-Troiose, die 20-jährige Schwester.
Die 20-jährige Schwester.
Die 20-jährige Schwester leidet an Hypo-Troiose.
Und da gibt es noch einen Bruder.
Ja, 80-jährige Bruder leidet an Asthma.
Und Neurodermitis.
Neurodermitis, ja, sehr gut.
Ja, das sind ja spannende Fakten.
Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Ja, meine Verdachtstiagnose, ja.
Die einem des nichten Angaben, Leuten am ersten, auf Endokarditis hin.
Okay, gut.
Kann ich Ihnen voll zustimmen?
Der Verdacht muss man äußern.
Was für ein ebenso wichtiger Verdacht eine Erkrankung steht noch im Raum?
Differenzialdiagnostisch?
Ja, als Differenzialdiagnose kommen tonsilitis,
tonsilitis, infektiöse Mononucleosis in Betrag.
Infektiöse Mononucleose, das wurde, glaube ich, vorhin schon von dem Kollegen genannt.
Ja, Epstein-Barbirus.
Aber noch etwas anderes. Denken Sie noch an seine Reiseanamnese?
Ja, Malaria.
Auf alle Fälle muss man ausschließen eine Malaria.
Der Patient, von Zeitpunkt her passt das durchaus.
Der Patient hat keine Malaria-Profilaxe betrieben.
Und er hat sich immerhin drei Wochen lang in dem Land aufgehalten
und ist wahrscheinlich umhergereist.
Da müsste man fragen, waren Sie nur in einem Hotel?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Also, das hat eine Rückpacking gemacht.
Also, Verdachtdiagnose Malaria.
Differenzialdiagnose endokaditis.
Differenzialdiagnose Epstein-Barbirus, infektiöse Mononucleose.
Vom Alter her passt das junger Mann.
Infektiöse Mononucleose kann das auch sein.
Die Hals, die Lymphschwellungen am Hals, die Dysphagie, das relativ übbar,
kann dafür sprechen, diese drei Dinge gilt es, denke ich, abzuklären.
Wobei sicherlich von der Akutheit ist sicherlich die Malaria
und die endokaditis führend.
Die infektiöse Mononucleose würde ich auch als wichtig erachten,
aber sie ist jetzt nicht lebensbedrohlich.
Ja.
Aber die Malaria kann das schon sein.
Und eine nicht entdeckte endokaditis kann das natürlich auch sein.
Ja.
Gut.
Danke.
Ich hoffe, Sie haben die Zeit gut nutzen können, wo Sie in Ruhe gelassen
wurden, wo niemand jetzt mit Ihnen geredet hat, weil ich glaube schon,
dass das verwirrend sein kann.
Achten Sie aber bitte drauf bei der Anamnese,
dass Sie Ihre Punkte systematisch abfragen.
Da kommt dann in dem Anamnesebogen auch das Stichwort
Operationen.
Ja.
Wenn der Patient von sich aussagt, ja, vor zwei Jahren,
bin ich am Herzen operiert worden,
dann müssen Sie weiterfragen.
Sind Sie, haben Sie sonstige Operationen gehabt?
Weil sonst, da ist man das schnell.
Also das ist gerade wichtig.
Dann auch eben gerade bei einem Fieberpatienten,
ganz wichtig Fragen nach Reiseanamnese.
Waren Sie in den letzten 12 Monaten, würde ich das sagen,
so kenne ich das von der Reisemedizin in einem zum Beispiel
Malaria- oder Gelbfiebergebiet, weil Malaria kann nach Monaten
erst auftreten.
Muss nicht immer klassisch sein.
Aber gut, da muss man dran denken.
Und dass Sie in aller Ruhe versuchen,
das Wort Übelkeit zu übersetzen,
Erbrechen zu übersetzen, Durchfall, Diarrö,
Verstopfung, Obstipation haben Sie alles genannt.
Und dann denke ich, ich werde das werden.
Und versuchen Sie, einfache Sätze zu bilden, nicht zu lang.
Gerade der ersten Satz, den wollten Sie sehr lang wieder machen.
Und das wird dann schwierig.
Ich würde es lieber etwas kürzer machen.
Sagen Sie ruhig, Herr Schlüter ist 23 Jahre alt.
Sagen Sie kurz, ich vergröße dazu das Gewicht.
Und dann sagen Sie, er berichtet über febräle Temperaturen
seit fünf Tagen.
Punkt.
Dazu meinetwegen, Abgeschlagenheit oder Muskelschmerzen,
Myalgie, Atralgie, Hyperheterosis.
Und er berichtet über zervikale Schwellungen,
Weitser als lateral, sowie dysphagie.
Dann haben wir schon mal ganz wesentliche Punkte.
Und dann können Sie natürlich Wert legen auf die Anamnese,
Beziehung mit dem Schwellen.
Wert legen auf die Anamnese bezüglich der Reise,
der Operation, der aktuellen Operation mit der Zahnextraktion.
Ja, ich hoffe, dieser Fall, der bringt ja so ein bisschen mehr
Differenzialdiagnosen da rein.
Dass Sie im Anfang hatten Sie ja die Diagnose,
der Patient hat einen Virusinfekt und klar,
das kann ein Virusinfekt mittels einer Epstein-Bavirusinfektion
natürlich auch sein.
Aber es kann eben auch deutlich noch mehr dahinter stecken.
Nur das müssen Sie erfragen durch Ihre Techniken.
Operationen, Reise an Amnese, gerade bei Fieber,
das müssen Sie machen.
Ja, das muss sein.
Gut.
Ja, ich hoffe, Sie können davon profitieren.
Ich bin davon überzeugt, dass es so ist.
Und dass Sie weiterhin gut trainieren.
Und vielleicht können wir das, wenn das so gewünscht wird
in Zukunft machen, dass wir eine längere Pause machen
nach der Anamnese.
Ja.
Würde das dem Moderator auch passen?
Okay.
Wenn das der Wunsch ist, dann komme ich dem gerne nach.
Dankeschön.
Ja.
Nächste Woche haben Sie seid?
Ja, habe ich.
Dankeschön.
Vielen Dank.
Dann sagen wir wieder nächste Woche Donnerstag um 18 Uhr.
Okay.